one show we had Keith Richards is the  host and he actually was like Robert  Mitchum there's the giant thing of Jack  Daniels in his dressing room because  because how do you write for a Keith  Richards you can't understand a [ __ ]  word he say well yeah okay ah there's a  lunch break I'm in my little place with  props there's a horse that's tied up no  one's around I see him kind of  staggering into view he doesn't see me  and he goes over the horse goes over the  hole she decided and he puts the horse's  head in his hands and he goes look at  you you're a [ __ ] hole and walked off  this is at so absolut you look at you  you're [ __ ] he knows that yeah you're  such a great thing to say you're a  [ __ ] hole you know but then you know  the same thing he picked up an orange  look at you you're a [ __ ] oh I didn't  probably does let some everything did  you figure what to say that's what you  say you're 3% body fat Mick Jagger